حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا لم يعد العالم عقب
الرابع والعشرين من فبراير 2022 كما كان
قبله اجبرت دول على اعتناق عقيده عسكريه
جديده وانقلبت اخرى على مبادئ تاريخيه
تغيرت دساتيرها تتخلى السويد وفنلندا عن
رفاهيه حياد استمر قرنين من الزمان الى حث
الخطى نحو عضويه النيتو خطوه ترافقت مع
قرارات لتغيير العقيده العسكريه للبلدين
الجارين لروسيا وفق خطتها العسكريه فان
السويد سترفع انفاقها العسكري بنحو 40%
بحلول عام 2026 وفي خطوه تاريخيه عززت
السويد وجودها العسكري في جزيره غوتلاند
الواقعه في بحر البلطيق على بعد 330 كم
فقط من كالينينجراد مقر اسطول البلطيق
الروسي تشترك فنلندا في حدود بريه شاسعه
مع روسيا ترى هيلسنكي نفسها مصمعا محتملا
لم فراحت تستثمر في قدراتها الدفاعيه اذ
تقدمت بطلب لشراء 64 مقاتله اف 35 بقيمه 9
مليارات ونصف المليار دولار ووضعت هيلسنكي
خططا لحشد قوات احتياط قوامها 280 الف
جندي مدرب وهو ما لا يمكن لاي دوله اخرى
في اوروبا القيام به
وحرب روسيا على اوكرانيا كانت طلقه
تحذيريه دفعت الغرب لفتح خزائنه لاعلى
انفاق عسكري منذ الحرب البارده فشهدنا
عوده الكبار امثال المانيا التي قررت
التخلي عن مبادئ تاريخيه في ظل الاعتماد
الطويل الامد على الوجود العسكري الامريكي
اعتمدت برلين تغييرات جذريه في سياستها
الامنيه والدفاعيه منذ الحرب العالميه
الثانيه بامداداتها العسكريه للجيش
الاوكراني وهو تحول كبير في سياسه المانيا
الرافضه لتزويد مناطق الصراع بالاسلحه لكن
التحول الاكبر في برلين كان رفع الانفاق
العسكري لاكثر من 100 مليار دولار لتحديث
الجيش الالماني
اليابان ايضا احد اللاعبين الكبار
العائدين غيرت اليابان عقيدتها العسكريه
جذريا مفصحه عن استراتيجيه الامن القومي
الجديده لمواجهه ما سمتها بيئه عدائيه من
روسيا والصين وكوريا الشماليه وعليه اعاده
طوكيو بناء قواتها المسلحه بما يسمح لها
بشن هجوم مضاد على اي طرف يعتدي عليها او
على حلفائها وطلبت في سبيل ذلك صواريخ
كروز يصل مداها الى 1600 كيلو متر كما
تعاقدت على شراء طائرات اف 35 الامريكيه
كما وتبقي اليابان على بنيه تحتيه قادره
على بناء اسلحه نوويه في اي وقت تشاء
بامتلاكها مخزونا كبيرا من البلوتونيوم
يكفي لصنع سته الاف قنبله ذريه في المقابل
تتبنى روسيا عقليه توسعيه في دول سوفيتيه
سابقه فضمت مناطق في شرق وجنوب اوكرانيا
مثل دونيات
ومن قبلها القرم يحذر الغرب من حرب جديده
تخطط لها روسيا في مولدوفا عبر نفوذ بدات
تنسج خيوطه في اقليم ترانسنستيريا حيث
1500 جندي روسي وعلى شواطئ البحر الاسود
لروسيا قدم ثانيه في ابخازا الجنوبيه
اللتين اعلنتان في صالهما عن جورجيا بدعم
من موسكو
تثير حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا رياح خوف
تعصف بمضيق تايوان حيث تخشى الجزيره
المستقله عن الصين من ان يتكرر فيها مجره
في اوكرانيا قبل عام
وكذلك قرار بجين التاريخي برفع ميزانياتها
العسكريه الى 230 مليار دولار وهي ثاني
اكبر ميزانيه دفاعيه في العالم ردت برصد
نحو 19 مليار دولار للانفاق الدفاعي العام
المقبل تشمل تمويلا لطائرات مقاتله جديده
عام واحد من حرب اوكرانيا كان كافيا لان
يدخل العالم في سباق تسلح فهل ينقلب
السباق لمواجهه عسكريه ام هو مسار فرضته
الظروف على دول ادركت ان حيادها لن يقيها
نيران الحرب